well thank you for the opportunity from
Pugwash to talk I gave a talk two years
ago I think maybe one and a half years
ago in Pugwash to a little tiny group of
people and it was fun and they emailed
me and said we should come back and do
it again so I was expecting a little
tiny group of people but we didn't quite
get that I am happy to see that more
people are becoming interested in these
issues and I think there's a reason for
that and we'll get into that as I talk
this is a difficult talk to give because
not technical talk is to talk about
philosophy in a way and emotion and
these things can be emotional and they
can cause emotional results in people at
the same time I'm not a philosopher and
I will not claim to have training in
that area and regime so what I say is
personal and hopefully the beginning of
a discussion that people can have but in
no way can it be taken to be the proper
semantic philosophical approach to
having these kinds of discussions in
general so it doesn't frame things right
if you will nevertheless I'll act like
one at times so leave me that freedom
please so I'm gonna talk about ethics
and I think the obvious first way to
start is to talk about my history about
my story of how I became a roboticist
and when I became aware that I was
seeing something in this that made me
want to act ethically and understand
what ethics means via via technology so
I'll take you way back I was at Stanford
University I was a student and I took a
class from this fellow Terry Winograd
he's still a professor there and it was
an interesting time because what
happened was a couple of things at the
same time I have sort of two slides that
tell the story of how this this
transformation happened me a little bit
one is the deads I took his class he
talked about computer professionals for
social responsibility the same time I
was working in robotics and there was
something like four faculty at Stanford
in the computer science department doing
robotics they didn't talk to each other
in fact they all had robots they didn't
communicate with each other they didn't
really collaborate with each other and I
spent probably six months trying to get
them to be in the same room at the same
time in an attempt to get them to
collaborate and they met in the same
room at the same time and then parted
ways again and wouldn't talk to each
other anymore afterwards either it was
fascinating you know it isn't that they
were angry at each other or mad or
unable to speak to each other it's that
they thought of their research as a
piece of as a silo is it
individual piece of work that they do
with their group and that research
inherently doesn't involve sharing even
with somebody in your own department I
was really struck by that and I talked
to Terry a good deal about that and I
talked about the culture of the
university and how one could try to
change it I was really upset that I
couldn't change it in that case and he
had this interesting counsel which is he
he said you can't change it from the
outside you can't change it as long as
you're a student become a professor and
then try and change it from the inside
and that's the only way you can possibly
have any impact and that was really
interesting to me it was very empowering
to hear somebody say you couldn't change
it unfortunately it was a rather high
bar right I'm a lowly grad student being
told first to become a professor and
then change it so you know both of those
are rather hard steps to take the second
part of that story of where I started
becoming aware of these issues has to do
with this computer this is the computer
that I did all my PhD research on and
would sit there and hack away and
Macintosh Common Lisp and write code for
reasoning systems and then put it on
robots and run them what happened which
is really interesting I had a fabulous
advisor named Mike Jenna's Roth who is
still a professor right there at
Stanford he had given me the freedom to
really work on a reasoning system and
connected to a really interesting mix
pick-and-place robot arm called Robo
world that was able to create little
circuit boards and that's that was my
world that was where I did all my
research his funders were the Office of
Naval Research and the Office of Naval
Research started becoming more
interested in something with a little
more literal application to the kinds of
issues that they were facing and so they
asked him hey how about you do a demo
for us where you're actually sort of
doing AI around the question of
targeting a weapon say for firing and so
he told me hey you know this picking
place is great but now let's do a demo
for them for a couple weeks from now for
targeting a weapon and that was it
right suddenly I faced a decision now
what do i do my professor just told me
to do something target a weapon Holy
Smoke this goes against me right this
sounds weird and I don't like the
feeling of this picking places much more
neutral than targeting a weapon
and so I thought about it and stayed up
at night and and said no I said I can't
I can't do that that that's a direction
that I think is wrong we have to do
research where even the short-term goal
as a demo
station vehicle is something we actually
believe in what that used to occur
it's the joke right that you want to
make product that you believe you want
people to use you don't want to make
products that you hope nobody ever has
to use so his response was okay good
do what you feel is right and he
supported me for the rest of my PhD and
never asked me to do the kind of
research again now I was lucky I had
professor who was willing to be that
flexible with me and who took my know in
a very very well-meaning way but that's
what got me really going with this idea
that even as a grad student you can
suddenly be faced with a decision that
you can easily be intimidated into not
making a decision that you can easily be
intimidated and not thinking about and
simply acting because that's what you've
been trained to do that's where I became
interested in these topics and when I
came to Carnegie Mellon and started
teaching classes here I taught a class
called Merkel mobile robot programming
lab where we had lots of students
programming robots in cardboard mazes
and contests they had little cameras on
them and magnets to pick up gold pieces
and these students learned all about
robot programming and in this class
every year I had one special section on
ethics and robotics and I'd ask a number
of questions in this section about
medical robotics about Defence robotics
about whether there should be lines that
robots shouldn't cross or their actions
or decisions that robots shouldn't make
and year by year I ask these questions
very rhetorically without interjecting
my own opinions at all to see what the
students would respond how would they
take this how they debate with each
other and I would say that in 97 98 99
I got fierce wonderful debates there
would be people in the class who believe
robots are nothing but a simple
extension of the current technologies
and there were people in the class who
believed robots should never make
life-or-death decisions so what struck
me as odd is that by 2004 I didn't have
any debate anymore everybody in the
class is agreed year after year you
should just let technology go whatever
direction is gonna go it's going to
anyway we can't control it
and so that was really interesting to
see the transformation in the people in
the classroom rather significant
transformation from an honest debate to
a situation where everybody was saying
well it's just technology it's gonna be
used in many ways we don't really have
control over that and that's really
where I started
I should I should tell you where that
comes from I started talking to my
colleagues in robotics and I described
the situation and one colleague in
robotics said something that I thought
was just a fabulous quote and so I'm
reproducing it for you of course I want
credit the person because I'm gonna
dissect it right but what my colleague
said is this we live in a dangerous
world and I'll do anything to protect my
daughters it's an incredible quote and
so many levels if you think and analyze
about that first of all this quote is
creating a casting of the world a
dangerous world
a casting that is stereotyped and so
broad that it essentially enables carte
blanche about what possible promulgation
our research results have because it's a
dangerous world after all
it's a dangerous place out there scary
and it creates a sense of protection a
sense of heroism I'm protecting my
daughter's the work I'm doing is
protecting my people my daughters so not
only are you stereotyping the world into
a dangerous place but you're isolating
partitioning yourself away from the rest
of the world you're different from the
Veii and you're suggesting that you are
being heroic in your technology creation
effort because you're actually
protecting your people so it's a really
interesting quote because it really
licenses you if you will to not worry
about the ethics of your action because
what you're doing has a reason and that
of his own death does not go away right
the world doesn't suddenly become safe
if you believe it's a dangerous world
and your daughter's don't go away
they're always around so you can always
make them safer by doing the right thing
not that I have anything against
protecting daughters I have a daughter
but it's the way that this constructs
what the world is and what my
relationship is to the people around me
as a technologist that I thought was
really truly striking and so we'll come
back to that quote but I think that's a
really interesting example for you to
garner what do researchers think today
and you can relate that to some of the
recent press like the wired for war book
I'll give you one more example like that
and we'll dive into it a little bit I
ran a conference workshop and it was a
conference workshop at the Grace Hopper
Institute which is an institute devoted
to women
and science and in this workshop which
was a tenant almost entirely by women
probably a thousand women were in the
room we had a keynote speech by Helen
Greiner who is the who was the CEO I
think or the chairman I think the CEO of
iRobot corporation formerly known as is
robotics and she talked about robotics
she started talking about the Roomba and
you can kind of imagine this there's a
whole lot of women who are
undergraduates from universities all
over the US in this room literally a
thousand of them and Helen's up front
talking about the Roomba talking about
the market talking about how empowering
it is for people to be able to use a
robot to clean up their homes and you're
seeing grins and smiles on the faces of
the people in the room it's it's a warm
happy room at one point two-thirds of
the way through the conversation she
turned to the defense robots that iRobot
makes and started describing them showed
the robots for bomb disposal and the
other robots for being able to do
surveillance throw them through a window
they crashed through the window and
allow you to drive around and take
photographs of people in the in the
house and as she described these war
robots these defense robots you could
sense a level of discomfort in the room
right it was obvious that the audience
was a little bit weirded out they didn't
really know quite what to make of this
they didn't know if they were happy or
sad or glad and this went on for about
10 minutes and I was sitting near their
front looking back at the audience just
totally curious how are they taking this
what are they thinking and then Helen
pulled the masterpiece act on this and
it's true but it's also rhetorically
very compelling and it's worth studying
she said you know you're probably
wondering about the justification for
making these kinds of robots well let me
tell you the justification she pulled
out some envelopes letters letters from
mothers mothers who had sons in Iraq
right then and there as soldiers and she
started reading letters by mothers
written to her written to iRobot
thanking iRobot for saving the life of
their son
beautiful heart-tugging letters and I
look back at the audience and what's
happened to the audience the audience
has entered a whole new dimension they
are there are tears in people's eyes
they are
they're thanking God that these robots
exists they're incredibly warm at the
whole idea that oh my gosh we've
actually saved the lives of people of
the sons of these mothers our soldiers
our people over there in Iraq it was a
transformation that was remarkable to me
and if anybody here hasn't taken a
rhetoric class here at Carnegie Mellon
it's very important to take that class
and understand how compelling ideas and
speech can be in changing people's minds
there were no questions at the end of
that about the ethics of using
technology and work or whether that in
any way changes our relationship to
humanity
to social custom to mores no questions
whatsoever about that subject came up
with the end of that and I guarantee you
that if she had stopped without pulling
out those letters there would have been
questions and there would have been
discussion about how do you feel about
these kinds of robots or their kinds of
robots you don't build is there a kind
of robot that's not quite right to build
so again it's a really interesting
example of how we relate to our society
and how we can justify in some ways very
rightly and in some ways wrongly what we
do okay that's the that's the
introduction those are kind of
experiences I've had that have been
really striking for me now the talk is
about ethics in robotics so I have to
explain to you what I mean by that this
is where I get to put on the philosophy
head that I don't have right I have to
understand and and communicate to you
what I mean by ethics for the talk to
make sense and for what I'm the
construction I'm going to show you to
make any sense so what do I mean by
ethics and ethics has many meanings and
you can go Wikipedia it all day when I
think about ethics when I analyze what
ethics means there are some routes that
it has on the Greek side that I think
make a lot of sense
one is ethos one is mores and I think
these relate actually to each other in a
really nice way okay
ethos is really about personal character
it's in a sense about the individual and
the make up of the individual it's about
what makes us who we are
okay mores is about custom and culture
and action it has to do with what we as
a society or a culture or a group behave
and what generates and constrains the
kinds of behavior that we have
so the two words together are really
interesting as roots of ethics because
one of them is about the human and the
character that the human has and the
other is about action it's about doing
it's a verb in sense and when you
combine them the way I combine them
again I recombine them kind of in a
conglomerate way to try and say what
ethics means is the responsible conduct
of an individual so ethics is really
about the action that individual has and
about how that conduct that the
individual has is responsible or not and
how one justifies to themself whether
what you're doing is responsible so this
is all a very long way of saying I'm not
going to talk about ethics and robotics
because robots don't have ethics and I'm
not a proponent of the singularity
concepts so no robots aren't going to
surpass humans and have ethics and
debate the ethics question the way we
are that's not going to happen right now
so actually we're not going to talk
about robots we're going to talk about
robot assists that's what ethics lives
and the interesting question isn't the
ethics of robotics the interesting
question is what is the ethical and
personal responsibility nature of the
relationship robot assists have to each
other to the technology into the world
and that's the interesting question to
ask and try and answer so let's talk
about that right
Epic's of robot assists so the first
thing I did is I wanted to see what's
published on this a bet is a great place
to go right let's go straight to the
accreditation board and see what
engineers as a kind of super set of
robot assists have actually published in
the greed is important and you go to the
abet dialogue papers and there's a code
of ethics oh good there's a code of
ethics outstanding now let's go look at
the code of ethics right so you go and
open up the code of ethics there's a
fundamental principles page the very top
outstanding and you can go look at this
up and you'll find us and the
fundamental principles are to uphold
advance the integrity honor the dignity
of engineering profession by and then
there's a list okay now I read this and
I honest-to-god expected that the list
had to do with safe engineering with
engineering that conforms to standards
with engineering things that don't break
right I was thinking like an engineer
like a technician
and I was expecting this to be about
being true to your engineering
profession but I was very happily
surprised to see that that's not the
case the first code that they have in
the Code of Ethics conduct in a bet is
this using their knowledge and skill for
the enhancement of human welfare and the
environment this bowled me over I was
really surprised and impressed that the
engineering profession has chosen as
number one on this list two things that
are highly humanistic may I say hard to
measure and not at all related to
directly the execution of engineering
but related to much much larger issues
around conduct so I was blown away in a
very good way human welfare enhancing
human welfare I mean this is big stuff
it almost tempts the ingenuity ask the
question is the thing that I'm
engineering is the widget that I'm
making actually enhancing human welfare
Wow that's a really interesting question
and the environment the environment the
engineer is supposed to pay attention to
enhancing the environment fantastic
fantastic that they're making that
connection to me that's a really
interesting place to plant one's rudder
and say oh there is a potential path
forward and so I have to show that to
you because I think that's a really nice
path now what's this
anybody know what this is a picture of
guesses a mine yes this is a mine can
you see the mine let me use your
umbrella can my pointing device here
that's the mine a little pressure mine
anti-personnel landmine thank you
so that's a mine and it's a scary thing
to see right it's almost it's almost
puts hair on the back of my head every
time I look at a picture of a mine
because you know the potential that a
mine has and you know how I can really
change somebody's life so I had another
colleague at Carnegie Mellon he's not
here any longer so this is even easier
this story to tell he worked for the
department defense on a mine except it
was a smart mind it was an anti-tank
smart mine that had the ability to move
it could actually jump around so the
project was build a mine that can hop
now why would you want a mine to hop
well there's two reasons one if a mine
can hop then when somebody's walking
around it'll hop out of their way so it
doesn't get wasted on a person because
this is protects it's supposed to blow
up a tank not a person second reason if
it could hop then if there's a tank over
there can hop into the tank blow up the
tank right and there's an interesting
extra reason right it's not really a
mine it's a robot now so anti landmine
treaties don't really apply now we got
into a debate talking about this
technology and talking about what he was
working out which was the hopping
mechanism and the decision
decision-making around that and his
point was I don't see how you can be
against a Selah this is gonna save lives
because it's gonna hop out of the way of
personnel and that means an infant
running will not get killed they won't
lose their leg because the mine will hop
out of their way and that's an entirely
valid point there's nothing wrong with
that statement what bothered me and
continues to bother me and makes me
wonder is how much to the systems level
is it the responsibility of the engineer
to think you can talk about a single
incident to child walking up to this
mine in it hopping out of the way and
their my their life essentially being
saved by technology but do you have to
go higher than that do you have to also
consider how many of these are going to
be deployed because they don't violate
some treaty or are these going to be
used in a more high-volume manner
because you know they're gonna get other
peoples away and well the logistical
tale be starting to actually kill more
people because of that right do you have
to think at that system's level you have
how high do you have to go when can you
say well that's just too high that's
beyond my eyesight I'm nearsighted it's
too far off after all as you go high
he's built upright you can't really
predict it anymore the systems-level
behavior it's a really interesting
question that bothers me or is it okay
to go just one level up and say in this
one sense I'm making the world a better
place I'm enhancing human welfare I'm
not suggesting there's an answer to the
question mind you now I have a movie
recommendation and I'm gonna show you a
movie clip and and then I'll actually
start to try and describe to you kind of
what the belief structure is under which
I try to operate my lab and myself this
is a fantastic movie how many people
have seen this movie by Sidney Lumet
okay very few it's uh-huh you saw the
remake there's a remake of failsafe
really oh it's like real time movie
there's a fun so this is the one where
Henry Fonda was in it so it's definitely
not the remake it's the real thing from
long ago and and some other famous
actors I have to set up the movie for
you and then show you the clip I'm going
to show you and I'm gonna spoil it for
some of you to some degree but that's
life and I highly recommend you see it
anyway I've seen it several times so
spoiling it doesn't stop you from seeing
it it's really an outstanding movie it's
a movie that was released almost exactly
where dr. Strangelove was released based
on a book that got sued by the book that
dr. stranger Strangelove was a book
based on so almost exactly the same idea
released the same time big lawsuit
ensued this ended up getting really
slightly later because of the lawsuit
and it didn't get any depress dr.
Strangelove was comedic and famous quote
that the producer had was I can't see
how you could do this topic without
being funny it's impossible to do this
without being funny and of course Sidney
Lumet does it at this he does it without
being funny in fact he doesn't by being
very serious what happens in the movie
to give you the synopsis is that America
has a fail-safe system to ensure that
there's never errors made and no never a
chance of accidental nuclear war and
this failsafe system is pretty complex
and it includes the idea that these
pilots have a special box and a eye box
that tells them you really have to go
bomb now and once it's told them that
they ignore everything after that
because this thing can't be wrong right
it's failsafe and once it said go bomb
you go bomb and nothing that you hear
will change your mind
even the voice of the president won't
change your mind because it could be the
Russians right acting like they're the
voice of your president so get the set
up so you know what happens right the
box makes a little blip makes a little
error right the system goes down comes
back up in the wrong State
one bomber goes toward Moscow so the
President of the United States Henry
Fonda goes down to a like 30 stories
below the White House that special room
you've all been to and he's sitting here
in this concrete bunker with Larry
Wagaman Larry Hagman Larry Hagman of I
Dream of Jeannie who's his translator
and much of the movie is the two of them
in this room communicating with the
premier of the Politburo right head of
head of Russia Moscow what's happening
is this airplane the u.s. bomber is
flying there Henry's being very clear
Henry Fonda as the present of the u.s.
that this is happening and I'm sorry we
can't stop it we've tried everything we
just can't stop it what can we do and so
they're having us back and forth about
what to do now throughout this movie up
until this point we're very near to the
end of the movie the part I'm going to
show you you've watched the developer of
this failsafe device and a journalist
and the congressman chatting about it
and at one point for instance the
congressman asked well what if it makes
a mistake whose fault is it and the
general and the inventor of the device
are in the room and they hear the
question and they simultaneously say
nobody and then they look at each other
in Google and they explain it can't fail
so it's nobody's fault so nobody's
responsible and responsibility the word
responsibility and the word fault come
in over and over again in this movie and
at the end here's where it kind of hits
a peak when what's occurring now is
Henry Fonda is is letting the moscow
president pop here and know that i'm
sorry
we've tried everything we can't stop it
and leading up to this he's also said I
know that if I don't do something
equivalent on the US side you're gonna
launch every bomber you have and you're
gonna annihilate the US and then we're
gonna annihilate the Russia and only
nothing left so I know that we're gonna
have mad and therefore I'm gonna have
one of our bombers go and throw a
nuclear bomb on New York City if Moscow
really explodes and we'll have a
tit-for-tat and we'll be end no more
nuclear war so we won't go
beyond that into full-scale mutually
assured destruction of both countries
okay so you're pretty nervous at this
point in the movie right it's quite
something anyway at this point in the
movie they're having a discussion
between the premier and the president
about responsibility so let's try it and
see if we can play this part there has a
chance of shooting down your bomber you
still left we do not think we have much
of a chance I know this was nobody's
fault
I don't agree no human being did wrong
to be playing where the brain both of us
we let our machines get out of hand it
was an accident
two great cities may be destroyed
millions of innocent people
mr. chairman today we have a case to the
future do we learn from her dude wrong
the way we have what do we do mr.
chairman what do we say to the dead
so this takes me to the part of the talk
where I'm gonna try and set up a model
for you it's a great movie you should
watch it and he's making an excellent
point is it possible for you to end up
in a situation where ethically nobody's
responsible or when you've ended up in
that dead-end is everybody responsible
all the way down the line and I prefer
the latter myself so that takes us to
the question of responsible conduct
ethics the way I defined it in terms of
ethos and mores how do I think about
responsible conduct I'm gonna do this
personally I'm gonna tell you how I
think about it and try and act just as
an example of what one can do in theory
so I start bottom-up at the individual
and I think about sort of what is your
personal agency what is it that you can
do and and the requestion I actually ask
at the personal level is am I being
truthful to myself am I actually asking
myself all the time if my actions are
what I consider to be responsible
conduct and am i acting in a way that
it's consonant with that completely at
the personal level it's it's almost like
are you sure that your actions are
intentional and they're intentional
exactly in the right reflective way so
that's one level that I think is really
important but we aren't actors in a
vacuum especially in places like
universities and businesses right
everything we do is suffused with a
sense of community
we're always acting in groups and so
there's another interesting question
that I think is much harder to answer
much broader and much more difficult to
come up with the satisfactory answer for
which has to do with collective
responsibility what role am i playing in
the groups that I function in and is my
role and therefore the role of the group
as a whole
one that values responsible conduct and
mimics responsible conduct and that's a
much harder question to answer right it
has to do with to what degree can I
steer the group or to what the green
chatter that causes the group to be
reflective to ensure that the group
actually is paying attention truthfully
to what its actions are causing so in a
way I'm saying personal is not enough
you have to make sure that as much as is
appropriate you're having the right kind
of impact on the entire group the sphere
of influence that you have within that
group and you know where the next level
is gonna be right it's obvious
it's the social good level yeah what
dick McConnell used to call Gaia in in
the design department here right are the
collective actions that we take and the
direction that we're headed consonant
with where we want to end up as a whole
culture or as a society in other words
is the trajectory were on truthful to
the places that we actually want
ourselves to end up in and that's a
really difficult question to answer
because you have to predict the future
you have to think about systems level
the behavior that your collective has on
the entire world on Society and whether
you actually hit it in a direction that
you think is better than other
directions you could be headed in so I
think of it this way and I try all the
time to think about whether I'm being
truthful to myself whether the
collective that I have responsibilities
in is actually being measured in their
activity and whether the direction we're
headed is actually a direction that is
desirable that has some kind of social
good and yes social goods a very loaded
word it's got serious philosophy behind
it but that's how I mean it so that's
one way of thinking about this from the
bottom up and I would suggest that as a
consideration I'm gonna give you a very
quick example and then a couple of fun
fun examples you know some of you may
know about a project we have in our lab
called GigaPan which is a little robotic
mount that allows you to take a digital
camera and make multi billion pixel
panorama with it there's a few people in
this room that actually work on that
project it's a fun project because in a
very inexpensive manner we turn a single
camera into this thing that makes
panoramas that have massive resolution
incredible ability to zoom in and see
things with great detail now one
approach to coming up with something
like this is as a geek you invent that
robot right you make the GigaPan then
you start scratching your head and going
okay now what can we do with it
what are the cool things we can do with
it but that's not how we function and
that's not how we got here okay and it's
interesting to show you through how we
got here we got here by asking the
question how can we foster a better
humanization between children in
different parts of the world how can we
cause cross-cultural understanding we
honest-to-god asked that question to
start with it's kind of funny right and
the answer in our minds was about the
power of the image what if you allow
people to do imaging in a way that's so
detailed that
fall into the image explore it find
details that enable you to have a
conversation with people around the
world because you're essentially
exploring a microcosm of them it's as if
everybody on earth becomes a Google
Earth producer they're making something
that has extreme resolution and showing
it with others so then we made the
technology as a technology that supports
that idea of extreme documentation of
your environment for the sake of being
able to dive into it explore detail and
share it with others the technology grew
out of the social good and that's very
unusual in a robotics department in a
robotics lab that's not usually how you
do business okay and I wanted to share
that with you because it's kind of
interesting this is different from a
standard thing NASA might do where
they'll say make a Mars rover these are
the conditions and oh by the way 10% of
your budget has to be used for education
and outreach so you make your Mars rover
you make your Mars rover and then you go
okay now I have an extra $200,000 that I
have to spend for outreach what are we
gonna do
should we give it to a Science Center
should we make a movie what should we do
it's completely different right the
creative act of being an engineer the
inspiration you take away from your
creative art isn't being directed
directly in consonance with the social
good it's an afterthought of course you
can do great good that way but it's
still an afterthought this is a picture
of the girls in Trinidad and Tobago it I
think in Trinidad and a prima girls
school who were communicating with
people around the world using the same
device in a very different context but
here's the big butt right even the best
of intentions can easily lead to
something that you don't want at all
this is a picture that kind of poor
tends to to that boy could you do great
surveillance with this thing Wow
make a 5 billion pixel picture from up
here you can look into all the windows
down there and the church and see what
people are doing do it at night through
an apartment building and you can see
what everybody's doing in the apartment
building right even if we design a
technology with a social good in mind
for that very purpose it's still
entirely possible that people will use
it for whatever purpose they want and
perhaps this has something to do with
this constant cliche I hear that
technology is neutral the technology
doesn't have an ethics that it can be
used for good or ill equally cliche I
say because I don't buy that
the question isn't where the technology
is neutral the question is is a
technologist neutral are you being
neutral I invented a technology or do
you have something in mind with it that
actually is constant with your goals
whatever they may be whether they're to
protect America or to foster
cross-cultural independence I don't care
what your goals are but is your
technology development neutral with
respect to your goals or not it's a real
question and one thing that's really
interesting about our society I'm
getting there I want to have time for
questions and conversations but one
thing that's really interesting is we're
empowering people around the country to
be able to develop their own physical
embodied devices right we're making it
easier for people to build robots not
just here but all over the country and
that can be good and getting bad and
again I just want to point that out
because it's interesting right
technology empowerment doesn't mean you
just get lots of good devices here's an
interesting example anybody remember
this thing anybody a few of you just a
few of you yeah I guess this is old now
this is Atlanta right Atlanta Georgia
it's called bum BOTS this guy has a bar
and he has a parking lot next to the bar
and on the sidewalk and in the parking
lot homeless used to converge and sit
under the blankets so he took a one of
these three wheeled machines that the
elderly sometimes sit on and zoom around
town the elderly people who have motion
impairments and he took a barbeque pit
kind of thing turned it upside down put
a high-pressure water jet on it give it
remote control it has a high fidelity
camera and he can sit in his bar drive
outside and shoot high-pressure high
velocity water jets at the homeless and
this got massive press throughout the
u.s. news system and it's a really
fascinating example to me it's
technology empowerment right this guy
has become empowered and how he's
expressing himself and empowering
himself is really sketchy so robotics
isn't neutral it's the person at the end
of the day I think we have to think
about our own scope of personal conduct
so last part of the talk obligation if I
were given the task of deciding what
somebody's obligation is here's what I
do for me and so this is kind of my
recipe book right but I think there are
action
items into they're kind of fun to think
about in thinking about being an ethical
robot assist so what is my obligation is
a robot assist in my opinion I guess my
opinion about my obligation is pretty
safe right no and I'm not treading on
too many steps footsteps that way just
my own so I'm gonna give you three one
of them is I think it's an obligation
for me to actively decide and become
aware becoming aware means reading the
literature it means understanding as
much as I possibly can about the
possible results of my actions right
it means blissful ignorance is
off-limits in my opinion and in my
opinion blissful ignorance by me is
horribly unethical I have to know
precisely what I'm stepping into that's
one number two equally important and I
ran into all sorts of people who didn't
do this deliberate you meet a lot of
people who said I want to think about it
I just I know if I think about that I'm
gonna get heartburn so please let's just
not think about it you like watch a
movie you know you have to think you
can't just become aware and then decide
okay now this is a difficult decision
let's not go there
I believe it's also only ethical that
you explicitly decide to deliberate and
make a decision and what are you
deciding what you're deciding what to do
but and this is where it gets a little
bit weird sounding but I think it's
really important you're deciding what to
do and you're deciding what you're not
going to do and what you decide not to
do is just as important as what you
decide to do and I don't remember who
told me this it came up in a
conversation with I think Terry Winograd
or Mike janessa with but it's incredibly
important for people to recognize that
every time they select an action they're
also selecting all the things they're
not going to do actively they're
deciding not to do every other thing
that they're just phasing out of their
life or giving giving up because of lack
of time and so it's not enough to say
this is good enough I'm working on this
cool you know targeting an acquisition
system because it's not too bad and I
kind of like it the question is okay
you're going to spend two years doing
that that means you're not going to do a
whole number of other things those two
years you're not going to drive any
buses getting people to appropriate
locations they want to actually go to
you're not gonna be working any other
technologies so is that really
okay and I think to be truly ethical in
your conduct you have to explicitly
decide this is what I'm gonna do and
these are all the things I could be
doing that I'm saying to myself and
deciding I'm not gonna do and that I
think is a very important step and when
you get there I think it feels really
good because you've actually actively
made a decision and the last thing
that's been kind of I guess I call this
optional it's been happening to me
recently is kind of fun I'm having
professors from other colleges telling
me they're kind of observing us you know
we have this lab here called the create
lab that doesn't do any defense work it
refuses defense funding it only takes
gift money and it only works on
directions that it believes have direct
social positive good so that's a litmus
test but now I'm getting professors
saying we're watching this is
interesting it's a neat experiment can
you do this for five or six years in a
row do you think can you bring in enough
money doing this if so we'll do it now
that's a weighty burden suddenly right
oh now I have to do it right but it's an
interesting burden because it's
propositioning that there are people who
actually want to act this way but don't
because they don't think it's practical
only practical considerations are
stopping them and Wow if that's true
that's fantastic
because you've got minds you can change
simply through action so I think that's
a really interesting result okay so if
this is the scope of personal conduct
you can ask two other questions in stop
one is what's the obligation of a
research group right if the obligation
of the individual is to think about all
these issues this is a research group
have an obligation if you're part of a
research group and I'm gonna claim I
don't know but I think the obligation of
research group is actually in a way to
think about all of those issues at a
certain level of abstraction to think
about what that research group is doing
and to actively decide on their own
agenda their own mission their own
vision and you can ask the same question
higher up what about University does
University have an obligation toward
ethical conduct of research there's an
obvious answer here which is yes how
that translates into action is a little
more complex right
what did Stanford do when they started
doing some secret work they created SR I
right Stanford Research Institute and
eventually renamed us alright not even
part of university so shave it off is
that appropriate I'm not sure that
sounds more like not paying attention
and pushing it aside right that's more
like ignore than actively decide right
it's like the further problem altogether
separate the problem from us so it's
interesting I would say at the bare
minimum University's obligation is to
actually and gender the right kind of
healthy dialogue about this right to
create forums in which people actually
talk about this to create classes in
which the students actually think about
this and are informed enough about this
to be able to be intelligent and
intelligible in the research group and
in their personal lives so if it's a you
know institution of learning we should
be doing that and a whole lot of
universities don't do anything like that
especially for their engineers right
they may say they have some humanists to
do this but does the engineering folks
in the university here get ethical
training how much do they get and how
far do they go with that ethical
training that's a good question last
what society's obligation well I see
some interesting signs here right if as
I said you know I saw this kind of scary
transition where debate stopped
happening in my class on these subjects
it was happening well 1998-99 and then
by 2004 it wasn't happening people
didn't seem to care or they didn't feel
that there was any line anymore they
were like well no you there already are
predator drones with weapons on them so
it really doesn't matter anymore we've
already crossed the boundary and
therefore it doesn't matter where we go
so people were almost almost given up on
the subject in a way I think society's
obligation is to debate this and to pay
attention to it and to have an active
dialogue about it and I was happy to see
Pete singer's book and especially the
reception received so wired for war
because he is talking about the
military-industrial complex vzv robotics
and I am amazed at how much press it's
gotten and so that fills me with some
optimism that maybe things are moving
fast enough now that society as a whole
is seeing the trend right maybe the
slope is high enough that people have
noticed it and maybe they're gonna pay
attention to it and and have some
dialogue around it that would be cool
well that's a hanging question I have no
real answer that was a maybe and that's
the end of my talk so I'd love to hear
comments and conversation thank you